we are oh my god embarrassing but we are
here for a very very specific reason
South Pasadena which I did not know
until I started doing these morning
walks actually has a farmers market
notice now I'm not saying excuse me
there's a lot of people there's a lot of
ways to turn that [ __ ] around see why
people the monitor you guys remember
when remember lynn from the from the
cooking videos so lynn actually recently
got married to our camera guy here Vince
yup and now she is finally finally
working
this [ __ ] freeloader she has been
free she had been freeloading off this
guy for [ __ ] years
okay what is your education in nutrition
and nutritional science that's okay if
it's speaking English South Pasadena
let's see what you got don't make one of
the socks ago
these are my dancing socks anyways huh
let's go to our first food spot I'm
feeling a hankering for some barbecue
Marco now I'm a big fan of bar-b-q so
this right here is the tri-tip sandwich
we have grilled onions delicious
delicious barbecue sauce that they have
made in-house on a delicious
hoagie and what we have over here I have
a beer brats for a brat that was a
terrible joke a grilled bratwurst that's
pork for you right there and a delicious
casing should be snappy right when you
bite into it we got that classic
jalapeno for those who like it a little
spicy with that little vinegar hit and
we also got that sauerkraut to balance
out all that bed and we added that good
brown ass mustard cousin
you'll put [ __ ] mustard on your
bratwurst to go make sure you spit on
your friends too
imma go ahead and fly into the tri-tip
sandwich first look at that smoke ring
on that cousin right there in that fat
yeah
i'ma take a bite of my breath American
barbecue legit it's all about the smoke
if you don't see that smoke ring and any
of the meats that you're doing throw
that [ __ ] away
how's them
you like it we also have a berry
lemonade to watch this all down I'm not
gonna really drink this on camera
because [ __ ] lemonade it's very good
you know Glen when I hear this type of
music it makes me think of a scenic
scenery
you get the character
sometimes I wake up I look at the sunset
and what do I see my fire
but naked with an apple in her mouth she
says I was hungry
what do you think I don't know I don't
even know what you just did that
[Music]
a what
what did I spy with my eye in the corner
of dime chicken thigh so there's a spot
right here right in the front of the
market where they do rotisserie chicken
I know when you think rotisserie chicken
and you probably are just like it's just
some chicken that you always see it's
the pasta but the difference is that
chicken fat on the books history was
dripping into the potatoes beneath and
I'm more excited about the potato guy
and the chicken but that's so
unattractive oh yeah I should have yeah
all the chicken fat dripping and the
seasoning from the chicken just dripped
down into those potatoes crispy home do
you see that crunch this is probably the
last thing that we're gonna eat here
kind of poor take a look at it right
there give them a little vision
oh yeah you didn't get the nice bag oh
yeah
Oh
I'm checking inside here onions we gotta
hurry
perhaps a masala
one thing about anybody you know for a
fact you're always gonna have mad flavor
but that pastry around the ship and the
moon is making the food taste better
[Music]
so we were supposed to show you guys how
to farmer markets and hypo fields and
buy stuff and produce but this [ __ ]
over here wanted to get ice cream we're
out here bunny get some Carmela's ice
cream
this combination cut us earlier that
species so hot she wasn't the cool girl
at high school stuff no I'm sick of this
cool people [ __ ] walking around her with
her [ __ ] flowing beautiful blonde
hair rotate that camera show the culprit
right now
yeah
at this you can see the Sun Sun is
setting in everybody's kind of packed up
so we can kind of I lost the purpose of
coming here in the first place I want
you to want you to close down a bit of
these real quick for all about fitness
fancy down that's it that's it that's
all you know how to say I consider to
job do it again and not do it again here
we go just do a sign up like this is a
business show David my little boy
running yet get them Iyanla by [ __ ] that
DS would you say
[Music]
when I wake up I'm like how
a lot of stars
season 1 we should monitor his injuries
what it likes you guys don't know they
grow tall as hell here is [ __ ]
Johnny you [ __ ] me up
I mean you mess me up okay